i got into an entanglement an
entanglement an entanglement
yeah remember when the word entanglement
took over our lives for a hot minute
yes well now jada pink and smith
and will smith's daughter is commenting
on her parents
little situation the kids see too much
yeah
don't worry jada willow couldn't be more
proud
i want to put it on the table i'm so
proud of you yes
on monday's new episode of red table
talk willow spoke highly on her parents
marriage even calling it real love to be
able to see you and dad do that for me
that was like okay that's a real deal
that's real love
the family is referring to will and
jada's very candid sit down
where they openly talk about their past
separation we broke up
we decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time
and you go figure out how to make
yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to make myself
well at that particular point in time it
was indefinite
yeah then jada admitted to having what
she called an
entanglement with singer august alcina
while she was separated from will
i got into an entanglement with
august a relationship yes it was a
relationship
absolutely fast forward to now the
actress says it was one of her most
vulnerable moments full blast of life
no i i i want to put
and just the total breakdown of any mask
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations
um with kindness
and consideration and it's just
something that we have to continue to
practice
because if we don't talk about it we're
not going to get to the other side
we're just going to you know things are
just going to stay
in the cracks and fester so the more
that we can bring these difficult
subjects to light and talk about it the
more we can purify these subjects
and bring them into something new and so
that's why it's important for me
jada's mom praised her for her openness
and courage
willow seemed to learn valuable
relationship lessons about how her
parents handled the situation
like when you can be like i'm with you
i'm going to stand by you right
and i'm going to hold your hand because
i love you
right and i think it's important in all
honesty for
daughter to for your kids
to have the opportunity to um
see their parents and listen to their
parents talk about
different stages of life that you go
[Music]
through